[Sylvia Brodach] I come from a family of six children.
[Frances Goldstein] And I was the oldest.
[Sylvia] Yeah. In between us, there was our
brother, Chaim.
And after me, my mother had twins.
But, ah, one of them died. Her name was
Freda.
Then is Judith.
And a little brother, Yankov.
[Frances] And we lived a very happy life.
My father was a businessman.
And we were educated in Czechit [Czech] and in Yiddish.
We had the yeshiva in the town that we supported.
[Sylvia] We never experienced any anti-Semitism
under the Czech government.
We associated.
My friends were Czech, you know?
So we had a very happy home life.
[Frances] The Hungarian army came in.
[Sylvia] And they occupied—
[Frances] And they occupied the Karpath [Carpathians].
[Sylvia] They took our business away.
[Frances] They just plain-blind came in and
then took over.  [Sylvia] They occupied it.
[Frances] And they told you, "get out," and that was it.
[Sylvia] There was, like, rumbling.
Rows of tanks were coming through the town.
And they parked those tanks in the center
and we heard those noises during the night.
And in the morning, there was a knock on our door.
And there were two SS standing.
And he said, "Let's go."
[Sylvia] Towards the end, they started to
liquidate the ghetto.
They started to ship people out.
[Frances] We went like they ship animals.
You know, those open trains?
[Sylvia] They never opened up the cars.
It never stopped.
It just constantly was going.
And we were suffocated, practically, there.
And because there were so many people
crammed into a small place,
there was no water. People were fainting.
Elderly people were dying.
And finally, after three days of traveling,
the train suddenly stopped.
They suddenly opened up the doors.
[Frances] And I heard they say that men here,
this goes here. The people start panicking.
[Sylvia] Everybody started coming—
[Frances] They didn't know, and they was going with
those rubber sticks, you know, here, there.
And we were very scared. And we didn't know nothing.
I remember my father,
he was grabbing my brother, you know.
And my mother, the four, the five—
the five kids. My mother and me, my sister,
we were holding together.
[SIGHS]
And as we come down,
they were... The SS pushed my father here.
[Sylvia] They announced it.
[Frances] And we go here.
And my mother was going with me, with my sister.
And they was 8, 10, 11.
They pushed her here.
And I remember, my, my mother—
the kids start crying, “Mommy, mommy,” you know?
And my mother pulled herself away from me.
And she says, [speaks in Yiddish]
“You should take care of your sister,
like if you were a—” [Sylvia] I know, Frances.
[Sylvia] The minute we stepped off the freight train,
we were separated, right there and then.
My father and my older brother went on one side.
My sister, she was a tall girl.
So they made her go to one side.
And I went with my mother
and with the, uh, younger children.
And my mother looked around.
And she says, “Well, where is, uh, your sister?”
I said, “They made her go over there.”
So she tells me,
"You run after her,
because she only has one dress on her."
And they pushed her in one side.
And I was running
from one place to another and I don't know how.
Because in Auschwitz, you just did not
run from one place to another.
But somehow, I caught up with her.
And, uh, I found her.
And we were marching, you know?
They took us into a section, where
all the women arrivals came in.
And that was a big, long barrack.
And you stayed there.
We were in Auschwitz for three days, in barracks.
And outside, all that going on, there was
a big band playing music constantly, day and night.
There was smoke, heavy smoke.
There were babies screaming.
You were looking where it's come from,
but you couldn't see where it's come from.
[Frances] Everybody was screaming and crying and running,
and they says, you know, "Don't cry,
you'll be after they go shower in there,
you'll meet them in afternoon to meet again."
[Frances] And since then I have never seen
[Sylvia] That was the last time we saw
[Sylvia] my father, my brother, my grandmother,
my mother, and the—and the four youngers.
[Frances] my mother, my father,
[Frances] and my sisters and my brother.
That was the last time I seen them.
[Sylvia] I had never heard anything about
my rest of the family.
Until one day, I was sitting by the window.
I was mending the socks.
And this friend of mine walks into the room,
and he said to me, “Sylvia,
what are you going to give me?
I have a surprise for you."
And I picked up my head,
and I saw my sister standing in the yard,
you know, in the courtyard.
So first, I thought I was seeing things.
And then she gave a yell,
and I ran out in the courtyard.
And we both fainted right there on the spot.
[Fred Margulies] I attended a, uh, Jewish
school—Adass Yisroel in Berlin,
as did my sister.
Most of the time we were very aware of the fact
that we live in dangerous times.
On Kol Nidre before we went to synagogue,
it's the custom for father to bless his children.
And I remember all the years that I can think back
that when my father blessed my sister and me,
he always cried.
And I assumed that
it was
because they knew.
Small as you were, you—you realized that.
And, of course, we were confronted daily, daily,
with a swastika
and the hordes,
and, in the glass cases on the street corners,
the display of the Stürmer.
My father would sometimes pick one up
in a train and bring it home.
So there was this feeling of
an impending doom.
He was taken away very early in the morning.
My mother was crying, and there was such to-do
that my sister and I woke up, and we went
to see what was going on.
And, uh, I remember the policeman saying,
as far as he knows,
that they're being deported to Poland.
And, um, that's the last time I saw my father.
When Kristallnacht came, it was a—a disaster.
And it became clear that life for Jews in Germany
was... all over.
Decisions had to be made as to
who should go and who should not go.
For example, one of my uncles and aunt
decided not to send both of their children.
They would send one child to test the waters
and keep one child with them
to see if this would work,
because there was no certainty.
It was actually fraught with danger.
And we were made aware of the fact that we
will be carrying a luggage tag on our lapel,
and all it would say is the name and
the district in Berlin which we lived—
no street, nothing else, no identity.
And that we were to act as though
we didn't know from where we came.
We left in the morning, early in the morning.
It was timed so that we would get to the border
at night, because we needed
the cover of darkness, of course.
I remember leaving from Bahnhof Zoo,
and I remember that not—
about a minute or two out of Bahnhof Zoo,
on the elevated tracks of the railroad,
came into view the hull
of this burned and destroyed
famous synagogue of Berlin, Fasanenstrasse.
And that was the last
stab in the heart for a little Jewish boy,
to see the burnt hulk of this famous synagogue.
I also remember very well that my mother took
me into a corner in this railroad compartment,
I remember well what she said to me,
in order to make sure I understood, because,
of course, I was a little boy very attached to my mother.
It was a great love relationship.
In that little speech in the train,
I always say I became bar mitzvah.
I have not been formally bar mitzvahed.
When I was 13, I was not bar mitzvahed.
I was bar mitzvahed when I was 11.
By my mother. No minyan, no rabbi.
I was given my—my orders, my commandments
as to what to do.
And I remember that.
I was to be the hero of the family—
tapfer zu sein—to be courageous.
And so the journey took—took its last hour or two.
At the station, as we got off the train, uh,
my mother said to me, you must not try—
you must—must not turn around and look back,
and you must not cry.
And she did not kiss me good luck—goodbye,
because there was just no time.
We went to the left, we children.
And I remember my mother and
the other lady turned to the right.
And that was the last we saw of them.
That was December the 6th, 1938,
in the middle of the night.
I remember having to go to a photographer
in Hoogeveen to have pictures taken.
I still have those pictures in
the little Dutch folder at home.
And, uh, we got to England.
And that was, of course, the last I saw of
my sister, who unfortunately perished in Bergen-Belsen.
[Anita Schorr] I was living, uh, with my family,
my father, mother,
and a brother, who was five years younger.
I went to school. We were living a life of wonderful
affluence and happiness.
We went skiing in the winter,
swimming in the summer.
This is, uh, my brother and myself.
My Jewishness was mo—mostly
combined with—with sports.
And we—we went Friday night,
sometimes, into the synagogue.
But it was more of an Oneg Shabbat kind of thing.
I know we drove with the car to the synagogue.
You lost your childhood, I think, at that
moment.
You suddenly were wearing a star,
and you were not allowed to be in a tram,
sitting with other people.
You had to be standing on—on one of the outside places.
Very similar to discrimination in this country,
where the Blacks were pushed to the side.
In Theresienstadt, at one point,
they were testing some, um,
vaccine against scarlet fever.
So people were sick.
Then they were trying to get
some vaccine for jaundice.
I was laying in bed with my brother
that had an enormous jaundice.
And my mother had
very dangerous scarlet fever.
She was burning up with enormous fever.
It was freezing. It was muddy.
They didn't let people go to the
bathroom.
And people had to relieve themselves
while they were standing with
tears in their eyes.
I remember one incident, my brother, uh,
telling my mother that he was hungry.
And she had nothing to give him.
And she was crying. And—
that was certainly enough for
me never to mention anything,
anything at all.
My mother said—now I was,
at that point, almost 14—
she said, “You are going to tell them you are 18.
And you volunteer. And you go, and you—
you go with the rest of the women.
I will stay with my brother.”
And my—her explanation was
that she has to stay with my brother,
because he would forget his name.
And I must admit that
I was very angry at my mother for
a very, very long time,
that she didn't save herself for me.
I passed through the selection.
I was now selected to go to Germany to work.
And I suddenly see that there was somebody—
they were examining women.
And somebody got up from the table.
And she was bleeding.
And I lost it. I started to cry,
“I want back to my mommy.”
And they couldn't quiet me down.
And a—and a German lady, a guard,
came over to me
and asked me, “Why are you crying?”
And I spoke very nicely German.
And I said, “I want to go back to my mommy.”
She took me to her room,
and she gave me cocoa,
which I didn't see for years,
and years, and years.
And she says to me, “Now,
I will tell you something.
And please, listen to me.
Don't cry,
and don't try to get back to your parents.
You are better off. You are here with women
that know you. They speak the same language.
And you're going out into Germany.
You're gonna—you're getting out of here.”
She really saved my life.
And then I found out later
that my mother, with my little brother,
they went to the gas chambers
the next day.
The moment we left...
The—the men left.
Then the women left for hard labor to go to Germany.
They took the older and the women with the children,
and they gassed them.
[Heda Kovaly] My father's name was Irving Bloch,
my mother was Marta,
and I had a brother, Georg.
Both my grandparents were farmers,
which was quite unusual for a Jewish family.
Both of my grandparents had farms
and my parents grew up there.
I remember my grandmother very well.
She was gorgeous—white hair, very lovely.
And she was, um, killed when she was
86 years old by the Germans.
There was, um, very little food,
the work was dreadfully hard,
and it was completely closed.
It was so claustrophobic and there was
absolutely not enough food.
For me, Lodz was especially horrible
because of the children.
They cried, and cried,
and then they stopped crying one day.
They executed—
I don't know how many people,
because I never had the courage to go and look.
Becau—they let them hang
on the square for several days.
And my mother went there,
because she said someone
has to pray for them.
From time to time, the Germans came
and they took people away.
The Germans went from one place to the other.
And then they let us go in the street.
And there was this—
always this officer—
a German officer—
who
said this person go this way,
and this person goes back.
And they took all the
old people,
and the children, and took them away.
We went out of the train.
And they—
right there, they started dividing women from men.
And I only could see my father's face.
And he said, “Take care of Mother.”
And that was all.
And I was—you know, I didn't see him walking away.
It was just such a crowd, you see?
And, um,
we walked, hand-in-hand, with my mother.
And there was Mengele.
And he showed my mother the right side.
And I wanted to go with her.
And there was a soldier, and
he threw me to the ground, and said, "You stay here.”
“Where are these people going?
What's going to happen to them?”
And he said, “Don't be hysterical.
And if you ask, you aren’t going to see them again.”
Very vividly, I can—I can see
pictures, like in a movie.
You know, I can see details,
but I have a—there is no connection.
And the last, um,
uh, night, um...
I don't think
I spoke to anybody the whole time
I was in Auschwitz.
I just lost all, uh,
capability of communicating with people.
And I sort of crawled aside.
And I thought, my mother.
I couldn't think about anything except
my mother.
Moje máma.
And I remember sitting on the ground
and hold up my hand and
there was this big, um—you know the dandelions?
And it came to me and it landed on my hand.
And I thought, my mother, she's here.
I thought maybe she just died that moment.